vasa sorry how's it going booze pack
today we're gonna play deputy dangle
surprisingly enough not a porno he has a
Brazilian wax as eyebrows that's great
I'm hungry let's go get some doughnuts
hey mr. cops whoa
all right it's one of these huh why was
I born without a skeleton it's either
that or I'm extremely sexy all the time
I have a feeling it's both all right
then don't worry about me Brett I'm
coming Brett anything for my prep right
I don't worry about it
oh no that's the bank name are those
arms chases Christ they could be
mistaken as octopuses look like this is
a time for sexy camp this is the result
of [ __ ] a snake
I'm just saying so any better way to
walk at all I swear to god this is not
how the game play looked like on the
cartridge I feel like this needs some
relatable caption when she says she's
home alone and you don't have a skeleton
I try I try
why why do I have this weird feeling
that I'm not playing this game right
she's right [ __ ] there just looking
at me
be like what a [ __ ] idiots gave me
one moment out I'll be all right I'll be
right there
goddamn it don't use the banana no she
used to banana I want it oh hey the
smoke bomb this granny [ __ ] is in India
investigate the car crash all right well
get the cat's back in the truck
hey what's that lady Oh sliding in your
DMS or a little bit sorry I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry
okay oh just get sticky all right like
hey thinking catch five cats I was born
for this ah yeah right me as kitty ah
yeah
phears geeky this is the weirdest [ __ ]
ever what the hell am i doing I'm either
being molested by kitties or now that's
that's what happening kitty temp I
noticed me come on
yes I have a hat come on not no yeah ha
ha ha gets cats into tracks I am a
cactus wait I'm a cactus know that
whatever oh god oh god no this is not
what it looks like man it's just not
what it looks like I suede again ah yeah
job well done the kitties are saved for
life all right let's go baby let's get
some donuts with my BAE this is truly an
immersive experience unlike any other
I feel like comparable to Skyrim and
that other game that was really well
shut up I'm sorry I'm so sorry
do you like rolling your thumb and your
gamepad well then this game it with you
uh yeah
I feel like I'm missing something aah
goat that's what I was missing
ok all right oh no it looks like the dog
goat the dog dangle can climb anything
in the game well [ __ ] me why don't you
tell me ooh kinky
oh hello yes Victor shun dangle Victor
Shangai Oh senpai notice me goodbye if I
noticed me need me hashtag relatable we
make jokes in this channel Bruce we make
jokes well pick up the donuts on the way
back well you and your [ __ ] note Oh
God
I love how I'm subtly humping the air oh
no it's the granny's fault ghosts what
oh so she screamed when the ghosts in
Durban Oh God what this [ __ ] she must be
possessed
now that's just my mom don't worry about
it she just guests will climb to the
roof then yeah baby spider cap spider
cap guess whatever eyes yeah God Oh mom
mom man
can't [ __ ] with me mom oh god she's
crazy no no no yes I'm not doing all
that [ __ ] again why are we saving
someone who's possessed can
like I don't think I missed that little
low memo oh god I think I'm stuck no no
no it can't be true ah no I'm stuck know
who that is
I must have the greatest ass of all time
if I don't have a skeleton like it would
just be the softest ass of all time I'm
on the roof and the game crashed oh cool
my game didn't save cool cool so cool so
[ __ ] cool
I'm so glad so glad so happy right now
so I'll just redo everything no big deal
alright we're back three hours later
that's great she's flying away um build
the super awesome device finally we're
gonna get into the kinky [ __ ] I know
what you mean with super awesome device
[ __ ] me I can't get over this ledge just
oh hey girl don't mind me just hanging
around well fine then where is this God
forsaken rope why did I climb this
building I did not need to do this walk
up in this [ __ ] like I was born bred
gone deeper with the spin like some corn
head make sure every barrel you did
taste
you have acquired a plunger gum what the
legends were true
this gun is super awesome no way I can
punch that bar can I punch please let
that beat the gun come on
gonna get you come on that head god damn
it
oh my god no yes gosh I got the [ __ ]
tail look at that look what I hit
destroy the propellers now why would I
do something stupid like that why
destroy the propeller when you can be
the propeller
no it seriously though why like I don't
know what the [ __ ] to do and it crashed
alright that's well this is awkward
um iris I replayed the entire demo again
the things I do for you bros that
commitments alright let's finish this
Beach did I miss some [ __ ] core
gameplay part as I cannot I cannot I get
off this tail and no no hahaha this is
my hat say on oh oh [ __ ] that's gotta
hurt BAM yes oh oh my god her face oh my
god her face what is it
how where in my life what choices
brought me to this place how did this
happen give me money
alright Oh money equals p1 of course how
could we have been so blind this is some
next-level Sonic [ __ ] right here we
found Sonic secret a lot of cash that's
yes what is happening then okay
I'm officially weirded out I thought I
was playing a dangle game oh it's a
porno again I know this music is
definitely a porno oh it's moustache man
what happened in recent and restarted oh
my god we're stuck in a loop that's the
core we're stuck in a loop we're stuck
in a loop we're stuck in a loop we're
stuck in a loop we're stuck in a loop
what I'm sorry like you're doing
watching say awesome raps
speech oh yeah let's get this crocodile
hey crocodile ha ha ha get up back up ha
ha